do you know I saw this movie I had no
idea you were in it I didn't know
anything about the movie except that it
was about that horrible story that I
remember reading the paper with John
Dupont and the wrestling brothers and I
watched I go this guy playing John dupon
is really good this guy's like a
breakout star he's really going to do
well I who is this newcomer I had no and
then about two days later someone said
do you know that's Steve carella I go oh
wow so was this the first time you
played a non-comedic
role uh no it's the first time I've
played a real life figure but it's not
I've done a few things uh I did a I I
mean not not to this degree no this is
the darkest thing how do you get a good
script like this you know they talk
about in Hollywood I don't care how good
an actor you are it's really hard to get
good material you know that in fact
actors sometimes you go well why they in
such bad movies you go because you can't
they got to act and you can't find a
good movie right so when you get a gem
like this do you know it's a gem right
away yeah well Bennett Miller spends a
long time between movies deciding what
he's going to do so what was the last
movie Bennett Miller did uh Moneyball
money bow he did capot and Money Ball
and now this and capot is like one of
the greats a money bow of course he's
great yeah so he contacts you my agent I
had no idea I I knew the story vaguely
but I didn't know it was a script I
didn't know he was working on it she
apparently threw my name in the Hat I
don't think I was on anybody's list
which is a weird name to throw into a
hat because you're comedian you know
people know you as a comedian yeah I I
think it was kind of out outside of the
box a little bit and and I guess it gave
him paus and he said oh you know I I'll
give that a a look and uh we met where
do you go to meet this guy I like these
kinds of stories so here you are and
you're intrigued because you probably
want a serious dramatic role every
comedian wants a serious dramatic role
it was a pretty great part so you get
this script are you nervous to go meet
this guy because you you're so hungry
for the movie no because you don't think
you're going to get it it's not like I
and and I really I'm not going to try to
impress anybody I'll just give my point
of view on what I think it is and my
take on the character you said one of
the weirdest experiences you were out
promoting Fox catcher I guess at the
maybe the can film or con film festival
or whatever it is uh John Stewart was
there too your old buddy from The Daily
Show and he's promoting a serious
serious movie that he directed and
you're promoting Fox catcher a serious
serious movie you did and the two of you
looked at each other and we're like what
the are we doing I mean it was so
yeah it was we were really uh kind of
pinching ourselves like what the hell
who invited us here yeah I mean we're
not of this World why are we hobnobbing
with these you know these Top Flight
directors and actors when I think about
you I still think it's so funny that you
ended up on The Daily Show because it's
not like you were the type of guy who
was interested in journalism no and yet
you ended up on that show with all those
guys who their whole thing is this
passionate political thing it was a
weird it that that defies job
description because you're as a
correspondent there you're you're an
actor you're an improviser you're sort
of a journalist right and then you're
also none of those things so I it's that
was a hard hard job to do yeah like when
you came in there were you nervous yeah
I would think that was the one that not
Fox catcher I would think the Daily Show
would make you nervous because you
probably like why the are they
hiring me it and what do you do you walk
you know you're walking in these
situations and you don't have any script
you don't know how it's going to turn
out and it's it's so
terrifying